Let's start with what's legal. Let's start with what we're allowed to hear.
我们先从合法的开始吧。先从我们被允许收听的内容开始。
This would be actually your off-the-shelf radio here. And so to power it up--
这就是你市面上能买到的收音机。那么，把它打开——
OK. And I'll go ahead and give you your short now. It's a 83-year-old male, difficulty breathing, O2 sats are falling.
好了。现在给你发个急救呼叫。一名83岁男性，呼吸困难，血氧饱和度正在下降。
811 receive.
811收到。
These are transmissions from a police scanner, a little radio the size of a walkie-talkie that picks up 911 dispatches, fire, highway patrol, the police. There are lots of people who listen in.
这些是警察扫描仪的传输信号，一种对讲机大小的小型收音机，可以接收911调度、消防、高速巡警和警察的信号。有很多听众在监听。
There's been many instances, where, for an hour, they've tracked an individual on foot, running through neighborhoods. And as you're listening to the police officer running and talking into his mic at the same time, and they're panting, they're out of breath. And a lot of times you'll hear an officer tackle an individual, and, at the same time, he's trying to talk on his mic. And you can hear the struggle. You can hear the screaming, the yelling, the swearing. And you are there. Literally, you are there.
有很多次，他们甚至能花上一个小时追踪一个在街区奔跑的步行者。当你在监听时，你能同时听到警察在奔跑并对着麦克风说话，他们气喘吁吁，上气不接下气。很多时候，你会听到警官制服某人，同时他还在尝试对着麦克风说话。你可以听到搏斗的声音。你可以听到尖叫、喊叫、咒骂。而你就身临其境。真的，你就在现场。
I have another party trying to get the patient to vomit now. We're trying to instruct him not to do that. He said that he is acting sleepy.
另一个人正在试图让病人呕吐。我们正试图指示他不要这样做。他说病人表现得很嗜睡。
811 copy.
811收到。
It's legal to listen in to emergency transmissions like this. But there is an entire invisible world, thousands of voices, passing through your body right now on radio waves, signals from cellular phones and cordless phones, military transmissions, and baby monitors, voices that you are not supposed to listen to.
收听这类紧急传输信号是合法的。但还有一个完全隐形的世界，数以千计的声音，此刻正通过无线电波穿过你的身体，有来自手机和无绳电话的信号，有军事传输，还有婴儿监视器，这些都是你不应该听到的声音。
I have a hard time accepting that. I think that if it's traveling through my body right now, why shouldn't I be allowed to listen to it? I don't care how sensitive the material is. If you're transmitting it through my body, I'm going to monitor it.
我很难接受这一点。我认为，如果它此刻正穿过我的身体，为什么我不被允许收听呢？我不在乎材料有多敏感。如果你正在通过我的身体进行传输，我就要监听它。
Today, on our radio program, people who are trying to make this invisible world visible, like this man, like many others, and stories of other invisible worlds.
今天，在我们的广播节目中，我们将带大家认识那些试图让这个隐形世界变得可见的人，比如这个人，像许多其他人一样，以及关于其他隐形世界的故事。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Our program today, seeing the invisible world, stories of what is all around us all the time beyond sight.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共电台联合制作的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们今天的节目主题是“看见隐形世界”，讲述那些一直环绕在我们周围却视而不见的事物的故事。
Act One of our program, Faster Than A Speeding Bullet. People who figure out ways to hide 80-foot radio antennas in their backyards, who monitor the radio voices that are passing through all of our bodies right now at the speed of light, and what they know that you and I don't know. Act Two, More Powerful Than A Locomotive. We've all been in conversations where something, some truth, just hovers in the air unsaid, everybody aware of it. In this act, we examine just how powerful that force can be with case examples from David Sedaris, Scott Carrier, Sarah Vowell, Brady Udall, and Lan Samantha Chang.
节目第一幕，《快过子弹》。有些人想方设法在自家后院隐藏80英尺高的无线电天线，他们监听着此时此刻正以光速穿过我们所有身体的无线电声音，以及那些你我所不知道的事情。第二幕，《比火车头更有力》。我们都经历过这样的谈话，某种东西，某种真相，就悬在空中没人说破，但每个人都心知肚明。在这一幕中，我们将通过大卫·塞达里斯、斯科特·卡里尔、萨拉·沃维尔、布雷迪·尤达尔和兰·萨曼莎·张的案例，来审视这种力量究竟有多强大。
Act Three, Able To Leap Tall Buildings. This is the story of a man who sneaks through back hallways, searches abandoned subway stations, crawls through miles of drain pipe, and in general, goes all the places that you are not supposed to go. And what he finds there. Act Four, Look, Up In The Sky. My friend, what sort of incredibly sophisticated species are we? We are a species that, to confirm the existence of one of the basic building blocks of our universe, a subatomic particle hurdling here from the sun all the time, we had to use some of the same materials that you would use to remove a stain from a tie. Stay with us.
第三幕，《能够跳过高楼大厦》。这是一个男人潜入建筑后巷、搜寻废弃地铁站、穿过数英里排水管，总之，去往所有你不该去的地方的故事。以及他在那里发现了什么。第四幕，《看，在天空中》。朋友，我们究竟是什么样的人类？我们是一个为了证实宇宙基本构成要素——一种不断从太阳飞掠而来的亚原子粒子——的存在，竟然必须使用那种你用来去除领带污渍的相同材料的人类。请继续收听。
Act One, Faster Than A Speeding Bullet. Well, it took a while for our producer Alex Blumberg to enter the community of people who listen in on the invisible world at the nether reaches of the radio spectrum, so much of their listening is illegal. But he found a guide or two.
第一幕，《快过子弹》。我们的制作人亚历克斯·布隆伯格花了一段时间才进入那个监听无线电频谱隐形世界的群体，他们的监听内容大部分都是非法的。但他还是找到了几位向导。
I'll call him George. We met over email. He said he knew lots of people who were involved in hard-core monitoring, illegal stuff. But he wouldn't get into the details. He said he didn't want to elaborate until we met in person. I expected a sunlight-deprived mole-man type, phreak spelled with a PH. But George pulled up in a red sports car. He wore a backwards baseball cap. I liked him. He said his father bought him his first radio, a regular AM transistor radio, when he was four or five.
我姑且称他为乔治。我们是通过电子邮件认识的。他说他认识很多从事硬核监控、非法勾当的人。但他不愿透露细节。他说在见面之前不想多说。我本来以为他是一个不见阳光的“地鼠人”，或者是那种疯狂的极客。但乔治开着一辆红色跑车出现。他戴着一顶反戴的棒球帽。我挺喜欢他。他说他四五岁时，父亲给他买了第一台收音机，一台普通的调幅晶体管收音机。
And from that moment on, I was hooked. Every night, before I went to bed, I'd fiddle with it. And I'd tune the static noise. And I always loved tuning between the actual audible stations. Every once in a while, you'd hear a station ID from several states away, sometimes, whatever, a quarter or halfway across the country. And it was just bewildering to me that these signals could travel such great distances.
从那一刻起，我就迷上了它。每天晚上睡觉前，我都会摆弄它。我会调节静电噪音。我一直很喜欢在真正可听的电台之间调节。偶尔，你会听到来自几个州之外的电台识别信号，有时甚至是在大半个国家之外。这让我感到非常困惑，这些信号竟然能传播这么远的距离。
At age 10, he went to Radio Shack and got his first scanning radio, one that tunes frequencies outside the normal FM and AM bands. In those days, the instruction manuals that came in the box actually told you how to use the equipment to eavesdrop on cordless phone conversations.
10岁那年，他去了Radio Shack买了第一台扫描收音机，那台机器可以调节普通调频（FM）和调幅（AM）波段之外的频率。在那个年代，包装盒里的说明书甚至会教你如何利用这些设备来窃听无绳电话对话。
And so thumbing through the manual, I thought that would be one of the more intriguing things to monitor. So that's probably one of the first things I tuned to. And sure enough, there's several. Dozens of neighbors blabbing away, talking about marital situations, everything.
翻阅手册时，我觉得那是监控中最有趣的事情之一。所以那可能是我最早尝试调到的频道之一。果然，有很多。几十个邻居在闲聊，谈论婚姻状况，什么都谈。
How were you feeling when you were listening to those people? Was it something like-- I mean I imagine it must have been a mixture of emotions as you're listening. What were they?
当你听那些人的谈话时，你是什么感觉？我的意思是，我能想象你监听时心情一定很复杂。那是什么样的感觉？
Actually, again, you got to remember I was very young at this stage, I don't know, whatever, 10 or so. And there were no mixed emotions. It was just plain exciting.
其实，还是那句话，你要记住我当时还很小，大概10岁左右。没有什么复杂的心情。只有单纯的兴奋。
But George got bored with his neighbors' marital squabbles. His radio collection grew to include declassified military receivers, shortwave radios, old Motorola walkie-talkies picked up at flea markets. He would listen at night, tuning new bands, different frequencies, fishing through static, hunting for transmissions like this one.
但乔治后来对邻居们的婚姻纠纷感到厌倦了。他的收音机收藏包括了解密的军用接收机、短波收音机，以及在跳蚤市场淘到的旧摩托罗拉对讲机。他会在晚上监听，调到新的波段、不同的频率，在静电中搜寻，捕猎像这样的传输信号。
I believe I had just begun to fiddle with the radio that evening. And I just got lucky. I was just tuning a portion of the spectrum that I usually don't tune. And very, very slowly was spinning the tuning dial.
我想那天晚上我才刚开始摆弄收音机。我就撞了大运。我只是在调我平时不怎么调的频谱部分。非常、非常缓慢地旋转着调谐旋钮。
All of a sudden, you hear this faint noise in the background. And you kind of zero in and find out exactly what frequency it is. And then from there, utilize the rest of the components on the radio to zero in on that frequency, pull it out of the mud, and you could understand by what was being said that it was a rescue operation. I heard one of individuals transmit their call. And I looked it up. And it was obviously a Coast Guard helicopter.
突然，你听到背景里有这种微弱的噪音。你会锁定它，准确地找出频率是多少。然后利用收音机上的其他组件来锁定那个频率，把它从“泥沼”中拉出来，从谈话内容你可以听出这是一次救援行动。我听到了其中一个人传来的呼号。我查了一下，那显然是一架海岸警卫队的直升机。
And it then became obvious that they were off the coast of Florida. And people were in the water, they were trying to pull them out. Things were not going very well. They could not reach the individual. And you're there.
然后显而易见，他们在佛罗里达海岸外。有人落水了，他们正试图把人捞上来。情况很不妙。他们无法触及那个人。而你就身临其境。
Time just starts to go so quick then. It seemed like I'd been listening for, I don't know, maybe 10, 15 minutes. But after glancing at the clock, it had probably been one or two hours. It literally felt like 5 or 10 minutes. It's almost like waking up from a dream, especially when you take the headset off, and there are, whatever, ambient room noises start to fill your head again. It's like waking up from a dream.
时间在那一刻过得飞快。我感觉我可能只听了10、15分钟。但看了一眼时钟，其实可能已经过了一两个小时。真的感觉就像5或10分钟。这几乎就像是从梦中醒来，特别是当你摘下耳机，房间里的环境噪音重新充斥你的大脑时。就像是从梦中醒来一样。
For two decades, George has been entering this dream world nearly every day for hours, mapping the terrain of the electromagnetic spectrum.
二十年来，乔治几乎每天都会花数小时进入这个梦幻世界，绘制着电磁频谱的地形图。
The portion of the spectrum that most of us are familiar with-- the AM, FM broadcast bands that you get on your car radio, your home stereo, whatever-- they're just an extremely small grain of sand on a massive beach. And the exciting stuff is really outside of that area.
我们大多数人熟悉的频谱部分——你在汽车收音机或家庭音响上听到的调幅、调频广播波段——它们只是巨大沙滩上极其微小的一粒沙。真正令人兴奋的东西都在那个范围之外。
It's a world that can be heard, but not seen. It's everything just rolled into one big ball. And people have to realize that it's vast. It's astronomically huge. Again, I've been doing this for 20 years, and I haven't even scratched the surface. I haven't even begun to get a grasp on everything that's out there.
这是一个能听见却看不见的世界。一切都揉合在一个巨大的球体里。人们必须意识到它是浩瀚的。它是天文数字般的巨大。再说一次，我做这个已经20年了，甚至连皮毛都没摸到。我甚至还没开始了解外面有什么。
Out here, we have a total of five antennas. The top antenna is what's called a Grove Scanner Beam. It looks like the television antenna. The little one below it--
这里总共有五根天线。最顶上那根叫Grove扫描波束天线。看起来就像电视天线。下面那根小的是——
I'll call this guy Morpheus. Morpheus is one of George's idols. George says Morpheus lives, breathes, and sleeps radio. We're in Morpheus's backyard, and he's showing us his antennas, three on the roof, each with a different purpose, and two more that run from the house underground where they come up at the base of a tall tree.
我姑且称这个人“墨菲斯”。墨菲斯是乔治的偶像之一。乔治说墨菲斯以无线电为生，甚至睡觉都在想它。我们在墨菲斯的后院，他正在给我们展示他的天线，屋顶上装了三根，各有不同的用途，还有两根从房子里引出埋在地下，最后在一棵大树根部露出来。
This is where it comes out. And these go approximately about 80 feet up the tree. If you look up the tree back here a little bit, you might be able to see them. I painted them a flat black, as compared to their original color, which is a nice shiny silver. You can see up there with a little coil.
这就是它出来的地方。它们沿着那棵树向上延伸了大约80英尺。如果你往后看那棵树，也许能看到它们。我把它们漆成了哑光黑色，相比原来的那种闪亮的银色。你可以看到上面带有一个小线圈。
Oh yeah.
哦，看到了。
Yeah, that's them.
对，就是它们。
He's afraid that if people would see two 80-foot antennas from the street, they'd break in and steal his equipment. Inside, Morpheus crams most of his gear on a beat-up set of wooden shelves. They're right next to the bed where he and his wife sleep, so if emergency channels start chattering in the middle of the night, he won't have to sprint across the hall to hear. He shows me a computer that, incredibly, gives a real-time readout of every city and county employee using a two-way radio at that instant from state trooper to municipal groundskeeper. He shows me portable radio gear and a safe where he stores two high-powered assault rifles.
他担心如果人们从街上看到两根80英尺高的天线，会闯进来偷他的设备。在室内，墨菲斯把他大部分设备塞在破旧的木架上。这些设备就在他和妻子睡觉的床边，这样如果深夜紧急频道开始杂音，他就不用冲过走廊去听。他给我看了一台电脑，不可思议的是，它能实时显示当时每一位使用双向无线电的市政和县级雇员的信息，从州警到市政场地管理员。他给我看了便携式无线电设备，还有一个存放着两支大威力突击步枪的保险箱。
Then he steers me to something he calls, "The great book of all knowledge."
然后他把我引向他所谓的“大知识之书”。
What we have here is a very large three-ring binder, a few inches thick, full of pages and pages of numbers and little  notes. What this is, is a compilation of pretty much everything I can receive from here as a personal reference. I've compiled this since I've been-- oh, jeez-- about 18 years worth of work here, on and off. This covers what I refer to as "DC to daylight," which means basically all frequencies from zero to a zillion. We'll go to the bottom here. Well, it's really low.
这里是一个非常大的三环活页夹，几英寸厚，里面全是页复一页的数字和小的注释。这就是我所能接收到的几乎所有信息的个人参考资料汇编。这是我自——噢，天哪——大概18年的心血，断断续续整理出来的。这涵盖了我所说的“从直流到日光”，意思基本上是从0到无穷大的所有频率。我们翻到最后看下。嗯，频率真的很低。
The binder is like a phone book except instead of last names, there are five and six digit numbers representing frequencies. And next to each frequency is a brief description of what it's used for. Morpheus flips through page by page and points. "This frequency is a pirate shortwave. That one's what commercial airplanes use to communicate with the control tower."
这个文件夹就像电话簿，只是没有名字，而是代表频率的五六位数字。在每个频率旁边是对其用途的简短描述。墨菲斯一页一页地翻着并指点着：“这个频率是海盗短波。那个是商业飞机与控制塔通信用的。”
Well, let's see. United States Air Force Hickam. Hickam is in Hawaii. Submarine teletype, nothing to listen to there. Shortwave broadcast. Ooh, clandestine military activity. And then these--
好吧，来看看。美国空军希卡姆基地。希卡姆在夏威夷。潜艇电传打字机，没什么可听的。短波广播。噢，秘密军事活动。然后这些——
He points to a whole range of frequencies, taking up  a page or two in the binder. "The Air Force's global high-frequency system," he says. The most powerful shortwave communications system in the world. It enables jets over the Pacific to talk to jets over the Atlantic. "If you get lucky and tune one of the frequencies while it's active," Morpheus says, "you can often hear the roar of the plane engines in the background. But you're not likely to understand what the pilots are saying to one another."
他指着文件夹里占了一两页的整个频率范围。“这是空军的全球高频系统，”他说。世界上最强大的短波通信系统。它能让太平洋上空的喷气式飞机与大西洋上空的飞机通话。“如果你运气好，在活动时调到其中一个频率，”墨菲斯说，“你经常能听到背景里飞机引擎的轰鸣声。但你很可能听不懂飞行员们在说什么。”
And what they do, instead of encrypting their signal, such that all you would hear is static, instead you can hear everything they say, but it's coded. They'll say, "Joker one, joker one, we have a message." And then this code comes out like, "Bravo, Delta, Two, Niner, One, Charlie, Foxtrot." And you get the idea.
他们不加密信号，所以你不会只听到静电，而是能听到他们说的每一个字，但它是编码的。他们会说，“小丑一号，小丑一号，我们有条信息。”然后传出这样的代码：“Bravo, Delta, Two, Niner, One, Charlie, Foxtrot。”你就明白了。
What does it mean?
那是什么意思？
Who knows? That's why they encode it.
谁知道呢？这就是他们要加密的原因。
Make sure everybody safe and comfortable. This thing's cold. I haven't driven it all day. And just FYI, no, I don't drive like a psycho.
确保每个人都安全舒适。这东西很凉。我今天还没开过它。顺便提醒一下，不，我不像疯子那样开车。
It's dark now. And we are, in Morpheus's words, "hot rodding American style" in one of his five cars, a black Monte Carlo, eight miles to the gallon. We're call jumping. That's the term for cruising with an onboard scanner, looking for action. Very quickly, we hear a promising squawk.
天黑了。按照墨菲斯的说法，我们正开着他五辆车中的一辆——一辆黑色蒙特卡洛，每加仑油只能跑八英里——在进行“美式热力狂飙”。我们是在“跳频”。这是指开着车载扫描仪巡航，寻找动静。很快，我们听到了一声充满希望的尖叫。
There's a car in pursuit. Eastbound [UNINTELLIGIBLE] 104.
有辆车在追逐。东向 [听不清] 104。
Oh crap, that's the other way.
糟糕，那是反方向。
We're stuck in a line of cars at a broken traffic light, and there's no way to turn around before we get through the intersection.
我们被困在红绿灯坏掉的车流中，没法在穿过路口前掉头。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] vehicle. He is running without lights. We just have one occupant in it. Very light traffic.
[听不清] 车辆。他没开车灯。车里只有一名乘员。车流很少。
Finally, we make it through the light. But before we can turn around and head in the right direction--
终于，我们穿过了红绿灯。但在我们掉头往正确方向行驶之前——
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] with one in custody.
[听不清] 已经抓获一人。
They already got him. That was quick.
他们已经抓到他了。真快。
They're listening for certain words, pursuit, structure fire, accident. But after an hour of driving, we've come up with nothing worth chasing. We all get a little bored. For fun, we scan some non-emergency frequencies.
他们正在监听特定的词，比如追逐、结构火灾、事故。但行驶一小时后，我们没发现什么值得追赶的东西。我们都觉得有点无聊。为了好玩，我们扫描了一些非紧急频率。
I want one Whopper, please.
我要一个皇堡，谢谢。
One Whopper?
一个皇堡？
Yeah.
对。
Is that all?
还要别的吗？
Yeah.
没有了。
$2.05.
2.05美元。
Over the course of a week, I meet a bunch of these guys. They all notice antennas everywhere they go. They all swap recordings like the one they played me, made with a scanner, of a madam at a Canadian escort service, taking orders and dispatching ladies over a cordless phone. And they all complain that the things they hear over the airwaves at night never make it on the news the next day.
在一周的时间里，我见到了不少这些人。无论走到哪里，他们都能注意到天线。他们会像交换录音一样交流，就像他们放给我听的那种用扫描仪录下的录音：一个加拿大应召服务的老鸨通过无绳电话接单并派遣姑娘。他们都抱怨说，他们晚上在电波里听到的东西，第二天从不上新闻。
I kept thinking that people with access to all this information would want to do something with it on either side of the law. Tracking police brutality or uncovering government scandals on the one hand. Stealing credit card information or blackmailing philandering cellphone users on the other. But they don't. They're not that choosy about what they listen to. What's thrilling to them is the simple marvel that voices fill the air, pass through us all the time.
我一直在想，拥有所有这些信息渠道的人，无论在法律哪一边，都应该会想利用它们做点什么。比如追踪警察暴力，或者揭露政府丑闻。又或者是窃取信用卡信息，勒索出轨的手机用户。但他们没有。他们并不挑剔收听的内容。对他们来说，最激动人心的是这种简单的奇迹：声音充斥着空中，时刻穿过我们所有人。
I don't know. I guess with all of these radio waves going through my body right now, I guess I feel like a radio sometimes.
我不知道。我想，随着所有这些无线电波此刻穿过我的身体，我觉得自己有时候就像一台收音机。
You feel like a radio?
你觉得你是一台收音机？
Yeah. Well, we're all antennas. And I guess I feel a true connection with these transmissions. I even enjoy just listening to an open carrier or just static, just static. It's the essence of the wave. It's the pure energy of whatever it is. I don't know what it is. It's a radio wave that possesses some sort of special power.
对。好吧，我们所有人都是天线。我想我与这些信号有着真正的连接。我甚至喜欢仅仅听着载波，或者仅仅是静电，纯粹的静电。那是波的本质。它是某种能量的纯粹表现。我不知道那是什么。这是一种拥有某种特殊力量的无线电波。
At the end of our long night driving around, we stop for one last snack before heading home. We were just talking now, joking around, trading stories.
在我们漫长的深夜驾驶结束时，我们停下来吃点最后的小吃，然后回家。我们刚才一直在聊天，开玩笑，交换故事。
I've heard the guy in the Mir space station talk. And when they've buzzed overhead, that's pretty wild even though, of course, it's all in Russian.
我听过和平号空间站的人说话。当他们从头顶飞过时，那种感觉真的很狂野，尽管当然，全是俄语。
You heard the guy on the Mir?
你听过和平号空间站的人说话？
Yeah, sure have.
对，当然听过。
You can hear satellites anytime we hear day or night.
你可以随时在白天或黑夜听到卫星的声音。
They punch one up.
他们会发出一阵信号。
That's a satellite.
那就是卫星。
[SOUND OF OBJECT RUSHING BY AND METALLIC SOUNDS]
[物体飞掠的声音和金属声音]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]. That's what it sounds like. Like a weather satellite. And that's with an ordinary handheld scanner.
[听不清的短语]。听起来就是这样。像气象卫星。而且这仅仅是用普通的便携式扫描仪听到的。
We pulled out of the parking lot. Our Monte Carlo guzzled gas. The streetlights lit the empty strip malls. And from somewhere in the sky, too far away to see, a satellite played on our radio.
我们开出了停车场。我们的蒙特卡洛车狂喝着汽油。街灯照亮了空荡荡的商业街。而从天空中的某个地方，太远而看不见的地方，一颗卫星在我们的收音机里播放着信号。
Alex Blumberg.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格。
[MUSIC - "TURN YOUR RADIO ON" BY ROY ACUFF]
[音乐 - 罗伊·阿卡夫的《打开你的收音机》]
Act Two, More Powerful Than A Locomotive. Well, in putting together this week's show, we were all talking about the various invisible forces that are all around us, forces that we usually don't think about. And somebody brought up the idea that one of the most powerful forces in a room can be the thing that is unspoken between people.
第二幕，《比火车头更有力》。好吧，在制作本周节目时，我们都在谈论环绕在我们周围的各种无形力量，那些我们通常不会去想的力量。有人提出一个观点，即房间里最强大的力量之一，可能是人与人之间未言明的东西。
When there is a conversation and there's something that everyone is avoiding acknowledging, avoiding saying, everybody feels it, and you feel its presence with this intensity that is all the greater because the thing is unsaid. The unsaid thing just kind of hovers there, obliterating all the things that are actually being said. It hangs there, immaterial, unspoken, exerting a dense emotional force field. And we thought, in this program today where we're trying to make other invisible forces visible, let us make this one visible as well. And to do that, we turned to five writers, asking each one for a story about some moment when they felt the presence of something unspoken.
当进行谈话时，如果有什么大家都在回避承认、回避说出的事，每个人都能感觉到它，而且这种存在感因为未被说出而显得更加强烈。未言明的东西就那样悬在那里，抹杀了所有实际上正在说出的内容。它悬浮在那里，无形、沉默，施加着一种密集的精神力场。我们想，在今天这个试图让其他无形力量变得可见的节目中，我们也让这一种变得可见。为了做到这一点，我们转向了五位作家，要求每人讲述一个时刻，让他们感受到某种未言之物的存在。
I'm having some pain in my tooth, my upper right rear molar. So I call a dentist, one I've never been to before, and he says I can come by at noon, that he'll take a late lunch. When I get there, he tells me the tooth is dead.
我的牙有点疼，右上方的后臼齿。所以我打给一位我从未去过的牙医，他说我可以中午过去，他会推迟午餐。我到那儿时，他说这颗牙已经坏死了。
"It's going to need four root canals," he says. "I can do them in 45 minutes. Some guys say they can do them in a half hour, but really, it takes 45 to get everything and do a good job. I'll order out for a burger and do it right now if you want." I say, yeah, OK, and ask him if he has any nitrous oxide. He says he has some, but he doesn't usually use it.
“需要做四个根管治疗，”他说。“我可以在45分钟内做完。有些人说他们能在半小时内搞定，但实际上，要做好这些工作需要45分钟。如果你愿意，我可以现在就点份汉堡，然后立刻开始。”我说，行，好的，并问他有没有一氧化二氮（笑气）。他说他有一些，但他通常不用。
"It takes a few minutes to set up," he says. "But if you're the squeamish type, I suppose we could pull the tanks out of the closet." Squeamish? Squeamish? This guy is going to drill four small holes one inch below my brain, and he's saying, I'm squeamish.
“安装需要几分钟，”他说。“但如果你是那种容易发虚的人，我想我们可以把罐子从壁橱里拿出来。”发虚？容易发虚？这家伙要在离我大脑一英寸的地方钻四个小孔，他竟然说我容易发虚。
He's about my age, a little chubby, wearing expensive golf clothes and a gold necklace. I want to tell him to [BLEEP] off, but I say, "Yeah, I want some gas." He tells his assistant, a young man, to set up the gas and then walks out to the front desk and asks his secretary to go get him an Arby's roast beef sandwich. The kid straps on the mask, and I start taking slow, deep breaths, trying to fill every cubic inch of my lungs. I start feeling it almost immediately, a subtle separation of mind and body.
他和我年纪差不多，有点胖，穿着昂贵的高尔夫球服，戴着金项链。我很想叫他滚蛋，但我说，“是的，我想要点气。”他告诉他的助手，一个年轻人，去安装设备，然后走到前台，叫秘书去给他买个Arby's牛肉三明治。那孩子给我戴上口罩，我开始缓慢而深长地呼吸，试图填满我肺部的每一个立方英寸。我几乎立刻就开始感觉到它了，一种身心逐渐分离的感觉。
The dentist comes back and shoots my jaw with Novocain and asks if I'm feeling the nitrous. I lie and say, "No, not yet." He tells the kid to turn it up and starts to drill.
牙医回来了，给我的下巴注射了麻药，问我有没有感觉到笑气。我撒谎说，“没有，还没感觉到。”他叫那孩子调大流量，然后开始钻孔。
I inhale longer, deeper. I inhale and inhale, and it seems like I never exhale. Nitrous oxide is amazing. Nitrous oxide is my very good friend. I hope to leave my body and float above the chair.
我吸得更长、更深。我不断地吸入，似乎永远不会呼出。笑气真是太神奇了。笑气是我非常好的朋友。我希望离开我的身体，漂浮在椅子上方。
While he drills, the dentist talks with his young assistant. He says, "So I hear you're leaving for South Carolina?" And the kid says, "Yeah, in a couple of weeks." At first, I think he's going away to college, but then the dentist says, "Well, say hello to President Benson for me. He's a great guy." And I realize then that they're both Mormons and that the kid is leaving to go on his mission.
钻孔时，牙医和他的年轻助手交谈。他说，“听说你要去南卡罗来纳州了？”那孩子说，“是的，再过几周。”起初，我以为他是去上大学，但接着牙医说，“嗯，代我向本森总统问好。他是个很棒的人。”我这才意识到他们都是摩门教徒，那孩子是要去执行传教任务。
I live in Salt Lake City. I grew up with Mormons. All my Mormon friends went on missions. I know the whole deal, how they take 19-year-old boys and screw them up for life. When I was younger, I was more tolerant of their beliefs and practices, thinking that this is America and that the Mormons can believe whatever they want, including the notion that God promised this land to them and that they are his chosen people. But as I've gotten older, I've become less willing to put up with it.
我住在盐湖城。我和摩门教徒一起长大。我所有的摩门教朋友都去传教过。我知道整个过程，他们是如何把19岁的男孩带走，并让他们一生都毁了。年轻时，我对他们的信仰和习俗比较宽容，认为这是美国，摩门教徒可以相信任何他们想信的东西，包括上帝把这片土地许诺给他们，他们是上帝选民的观念。但随着年龄增长，我越来越不愿意容忍这些。
I don't believe that their patriarch Joseph Smith was visited by an angel who showed him where some golden plates were buried in upstate New York. I don't believe the plates were a record of a people written in reformed Egyptian hieroglyphics, which Joseph Smith then translated through the miraculous aid of a seer stone and a breastplate-type device he called the Urim and Thummim. And more than anything, I can't believe I'm letting a man who does believe in all of this drill small holes in my head. There were no golden plates. There were no golden plates. There were no golden plates.
我不相信他们的族长约瑟夫·史密斯曾得到过天使的探访，天使指引他找到了埋在纽约州北部的一些金页片。我不相信那些页片是用改写后的埃及象形文字记录的人民历史，约瑟夫·史密斯后来通过一块先见之石和一个他称之为“乌陵和土明”的胸甲装置奇迹般地翻译了出来。最重要的是，我无法相信我竟然让一个相信这一切的男人在我的头上钻小孔。根本没有金页片。没有金页片。没有金页片。
The dentist asked me, "How's that gas doing? Feeling no pain, huh?" And both he and his young assistant laugh at me. I groan like it's not working. And again, he tells the kid to turn it up.
牙医问我，“气怎么样？感觉不到痛吧？”他和他的年轻助手都嘲笑我。我呻吟着，好像没起作用。他再次告诉那孩子调大流量。
I take a long, hard bong hit, and it's all settled now. I know the dentist is a Mormon, and he knows I'm a druggie. That even though we've just met, it's like we've known each other for 25 years since we went to different high schools together, back when he gave up masturbating in order to get into the celestial kingdom, back when I gave up all respect for authority and tried to leave town forever. He knows he doesn't like me, and I know I don't like him. And we both know he's charging $1,000 an hour for his time, and that I will pay off the bill very slowly, finishing some time just before Jesus comes back.
我深吸了一大口，现在一切都安定了。我知道牙医是摩门教徒，他也知道我是个瘾君子。虽然我们才刚见面，但感觉就像我们认识25年了，尽管我们上了不同的高中，那时他为了进入“高荣国”而放弃了自慰，而我放弃了对权威的所有尊重，试图永远离开这个城镇。他知道他不怎么喜欢我，我也知道我不喜欢他。而且我们都知道他每小时收费1000美元，而我会分期付款慢慢还，大概在耶稣回来前不久能还清。
A woman I once worked for came to Paris on vacation, and we went for lunch at a little restaurant around the corner from my apartment. We'd just sat down when she cleared her throat saying, "I don't know if I ever told you this, but I really didn't think much of your last book." This came out of nowhere. It was as if she'd looked on the menu and read that the chef's suggestion was to tell someone what you really thought.
我曾经工作过的一位女士来巴黎度假，我们在我公寓附近的一家小餐厅吃了午饭。我们刚坐下，她就清了清嗓子说：“不知道我有没有告诉过你，但我真的很不喜欢你的上一本书。”这简直是莫名其妙。就好像她看了菜单，上面写着“厨师推荐：告诉某人你的真实想法”。
I one-upped her, saying that she couldn't have hated the book half as much as I did. And this set the tone for the rest of the afternoon, both of us agreeing that my life was decidedly second-rate. After our lunch, we were standing in front of my apartment, her deciding that the building was unremarkable and me conceding that yes, it was. We said goodbye, and then she lurched forward, subjecting me to a hug, which I really wasn't expecting at all. I never hug anyone if I can help it.
我回击了她，说她不可能比我更讨厌那本书。这奠定了那天下午剩下时间的基调，我们两人都一致认为我的生活显然是二流的。午饭后，我们站在我的公寓前，她断定这栋建筑平淡无奇，我表示赞同，确实如此。我们道别，然后她猛地向前一步，强行给我一个拥抱，这真是我没料到的。如果可以，我从来不拥抱任何人。
To make things just that much more awkward, I was holding a lit cigarette that proceeded to burn a hole in her obviously new and first-rate jacket. We both knew what had happened. She caught me staring at the hole, and then she caught me deadening my gaze and pretending to be lost in thought. It was clearly my responsibility to acknowledge what had happened, to offer to pay for the coat, or at least to apologize. I was close to cracking, and then I decided that, while it had been my cigarette, it had definitely not been my hug.
为了让事情变得更尴尬，我手里拿着一支点燃的香烟，它在那件显然是新的、高档的外套上烧了一个洞。我们都知道发生了什么。她发现我在盯着那个洞，然后她看到我眼神涣散，假装陷入沉思。显然我有责任承认刚才发生的事，提出赔偿那件外套，或者至少道歉。我几乎要崩溃了，但我决定，虽然是我的香烟烧的，但绝对不是我要拥抱的。
And so we stood there for what seemed like hours, one of us introducing a possible conclusion, and the other one rephrasing it. "Well, all right then." "OK." "So--" "Well--" "Golly." "Gosh." "Well, what do you know."
于是我们就那样站着，仿佛过了好几个小时，一个人引入了一个可能的结论，另一个人又重复了一遍。“嗯，好吧。”“好的。”“那么——”“嗯——”“天哪。”“哎呀。”“好吧，那又怎样。”
"Still married?" I ask him on the way to lunch. "Unfortunately," he answers. He laughs. I laugh. That's the only thing we say about it, his being married, me wishing he wasn't, the both of us wondering if this lunch is such a good idea considering the feeling we both get around each other.
“还结婚吗？”我在去吃午饭的路上问他。“不幸的是，”他回答。他笑了。我笑了。关于他的婚姻，关于我希望他没结婚，以及我们两个都在想，考虑到我们在一起时的那种感觉，这顿午饭是否是个好主意，这是我们唯一说的话。
I have an ulterior motive for this little get-together. My hope is that by the end of the lunch, I'll like him less. We have a lot to talk about, a lot in common-- music, movies, history, books. I avoid these topics and steer the conversation towards politics. He's a republican, and let's just say, I have an LBJ keychain in my pocket.
我这次小聚会有个不可告人的动机。我希望午饭结束时，我会少喜欢他一点。我们有很多共同话题，很多共同点——音乐、电影、历史、书籍。但我避开了这些话题，把谈话引向政治。他是共和党人，我们可以这么说，我的口袋里有一个LBJ（林登·约翰逊）钥匙扣。
Actually, he's a libertarian which, as near as I can tell, is just a republican who doesn't believe in God. He's really excited about the flat tax. The more he goes on about the flat tax, the more thrilled I feel because I loathe the flat tax. I keep nodding along, "Uh-huh, uh-huh, really?"
其实，他是自由意志主义者，据我所知，这只是一个不相信上帝的共和党人。他对比率税（flat tax）非常兴奋。他越是滔滔不绝地讲比率税，我就越觉得反感，因为我厌恶比率税。我一直跟着点头，“嗯哼，嗯哼，真的吗？”
All the while, I'm telling myself, "See, I can't fall for a flat taxer. The flat tax is about greed. I'm about civic duty, tax and spend, tax and spend." It works. For, what is less sexy than the mention of Steve Forbes?
与此同时，我一直在对自己说：“看，我不能爱上一个比率税支持者。比率税是关于贪婪的。我关心的 civic duty（公民义务）、征税和支出。”这招很管用。毕竟，还有什么比提到史蒂夫·福布斯更让人性冷淡的呢？
I run through all the usual issues. Unfortunately, we agree about abortion and gun control and education. I start going soft, doddering on about assault rifles, all the while noticing his hand resting there on the table so near my own. It would be so easy, so quick to just reach for it-- his hand. But there is that wedding ring on one of his fingers. I look up, stare deep into his eyes and say, "So you didn't happen to vote for Ross Perot, did you?"
我过了一遍所有通常的话题。不幸的是，我们在堕胎、枪支管制和教育方面意见一致。我开始心软了，唠唠叨叨地谈论突击步枪，同时注意到他的手就放在桌子上，离我的手如此之近。如果伸手去抓他的手，那将会是多么容易、多么迅速。但他的手指上戴着那枚结婚戒指。我抬起头，盯着他的眼睛说：“所以你没投罗斯·佩罗的票吧？”
My eight-year-old son found a wig in the garbage dumpster this morning. I walked into the kitchen, highly irritated that I couldn't make a respectable knot in my green paisley tie. And there he was at the table, eating cereal and reading the funnies, the wig pulled tightly over his head like a football helmet. The wig was a dirty bush of curly blond hair, the kind you might see on a prostitute or someone who is trying to imitate Marilyn Monroe.
我八岁的儿子今天早上在垃圾箱里发现了一顶假发。我走进厨房，因为没法把我的绿色腰果花领带系出一个像样的结而感到非常恼火。而他就在桌子边，一边吃麦片一边看漫画，假发紧紧地套在他的头上，像个橄榄球头盔。那假发是一团脏兮兮的卷曲金发，你在妓女或者模仿玛丽莲·梦露的人头上可能会看到的那种。
I asked him where he got the wig, and he told me, his mouth full of cereal. When I advised him that we don't wear things that we find in the garbage, he simply continued eating and reading as if he didn't hear me. I wanted him to take that wig off, but I couldn't ask him to do it. I forgot all about my tie and going to work. I looked out the window where a mist fell slowly on the street.
我问他从哪弄来的假发，他满嘴麦片地告诉了我。当我劝告他说我们不戴在垃圾堆里捡的东西时，他只是继续吃着看着，好像没听见我说话。我想让他摘下那顶假发，但我开不了口。我彻底忘了我的领带和要去上班的事。我望向窗外，细雨缓慢地落在街道上。
I paced into the living room and back, trying not to look at my son. He ignored me. I could hear him munching cereal and rustling paper. There was a picture or a memory, real or imagined, that I couldn't get out of my mind. Last spring, before the accident, my wife was sitting in the chair where now my son always sits. She was reading the paper to see how the Blackhawks did the night before, and her sleep-mussed hair was only slightly longer and darker than the hair of my son's wig.
我在客厅里踱来踱去，尽量不去看我的儿子。他无视我。我能听到他咀嚼麦片和翻动纸张的声音。有一个画面或记忆，真实的或想象的，在我脑海里挥之不去。去年春天，事故发生前，我的妻子坐在现在我儿子总是坐的那张椅子上。她在看报纸，想看看昨晚黑鹰队比赛的结果，她睡乱的头发只比我儿子假发上的头发稍长、稍深一点。
I wondered if my son had a similar picture in his head, or if he had a picture at all. I watched him, and he finally looked up at me, but his face was blank. He went back to his reading. I walked around the table, picked him up, and held him against my chest. I pressed my nose into that wig, and it smelled not like the clean shampoo scent I might have been hoping for, but like old lettuce. I suppose it didn't matter at that point. My son put his smooth arms around my neck, and for maybe a few seconds, we were together again, the three of us.
我想知道我的儿子脑子里是否有类似的画面，或者他是否根本没有任何画面。我注视着他，他终于抬头看了我一眼，但他的表情是空白的。他又回到了阅读中。我绕过桌子，抱起他，把他按在我的胸前。我把鼻子埋进那顶假发里，它闻起来没有我希望的那种干净的洗发水香味，而是像陈年的生菜味。我想那在那一刻已经不重要了。我的儿子把细嫩的胳膊搂在我的脖子上，在那几秒钟里，我们三个人又在一起了。
Before my grandmother died, she brought my sister Sally and me to a fortune teller in Chinatown who never made mistakes. My grandmother believed in fate. She believed that the twists and turns of our lives were mapped out at birth, as clear as pages from a book of standard plotlines. I, on the other hand, was a rationalist and a skeptic. And Sally was simply distracted. She was the beautiful one. She was getting married, and she had her own life.
在我祖母去世前，她带我和我姐姐莎莉去唐人街找一位算命先生，他从来没算错过。我祖母相信命运。她相信我们生活的曲折是出生时就注定的，就像标准情节书里的书页一样清晰。而我，是一个理智主义者和怀疑论者。莎莉只是心不在焉。她是那个漂亮的。她快要结婚了，她有自己的生活。
The fortune teller was a tall Buddhist monk whose huge bald head startled me. He studied my palm, pressed my hands, and peered into my face. His eyes were shrewd and bright. In that moment, I forgot I was a rationalist. I wanted his opinion of me.
那位算命先生是一个高个子的佛教僧人，他巨大的秃头吓了我一跳。他研究了我的手掌，按压了我的手，凝视着我的脸。他的眼睛锐利而明亮。那一刻，我忘记了自己是一个理智主义者。我想得到他的评价。
The fortune teller and my grandmother faced each other, talking rapidly, moving their hands. They spoke in a Sichuan dialect I could not decipher. My future floated through the air in inaccessible words. I waited for the translation. Maybe I would learn who I would marry. Maybe I would find out if I could pursue my ambition of becoming a writer.
算命先生和祖母面对面，快速地交谈，挥动手臂。他们用一种我听不懂的四川话交流。我的未来在那些无法理解的文字中飘荡。我等待着翻译。也许我会知道我会嫁给谁。也许我会发现我是否能实现成为作家的抱负。
Finally, after several minutes, the monk turned back to me. He said, in English, "You should eat more slowly. Eat less oil. Exercise." Then he beckoned to my sister.
最后，几分钟后，僧人转过头看着我。他用英语说：“你应该吃慢点。少吃油。多锻炼。”然后他向我姐姐招手。
I stood with my mouth open, furious, as he spoke to Sally. Eat more slowly? Eat less grease? Was I destined to die of heart failure? The monk was holding out on me.
我张着嘴站在那儿，怒不可遏，听着他对莎莉说话。吃慢点？少吃油？难道我注定要死于心脏衰竭吗？这僧人对我有所保留。
The more I thought about it, the more I had to know. But my grandmother refused to talk. She would ignore my questions and plant herself at the kitchen table, spreading hot pepper sauce on whole wheat toast and shaking her head. In the next few years, I could only pry from her a few vague pieces of information, and what I learned wasn't comforting. She said I would have money and fame, but that my luck would not be steady.
我想得越多，就越想知道。但祖母拒绝开口。她会无视我的问题，坐在厨房桌子旁，在全麦吐司上涂抹辣酱，然后摇着头。在接下来的几年里，我只能从她那里打听到一些模糊的信息，而我所学到的并没有带来安慰。她说我会拥有金钱和名声，但运气不会稳定。
She especially wouldn't talk about Sally who had always been her favorite. "She has peach blossom luck," she told me once. A few months later, my grandmother died. Since then, I've asked about peach blossom luck, but the explanations are never the same. "Too much desired," someone once said. And I wondered what was wrong with that.
她特别不愿谈论莎莉，莎莉一直是她最喜欢的。“她有桃花运，”她曾对我说。几个月后，祖母去世了。从那以后，我问过关于“桃花运”的事，但解释从不相同。“想要的东西太多了，”有人曾经说。我好奇这有什么错。
It's only recently, since my sister's divorce, that I've begun to see how complicated being desired is. Nowadays, I live a rational life. I write in the morning. I meet my sister for lunch, and we talk about our relationships. We tell each other, we need to learn to let go, stop trying to control the outcome.
直到最近，在我姐姐离婚后，我才开始明白成为被渴望的对象是多么复杂。如今，我过着理智的生活。我早上写作。我和姐姐午餐聚会，我们谈论彼此的关系。我们告诉对方，我们需要学会放手，停止试图控制结果。
But in the back of my mind, I'm standing with Sally in the darkened room of a Chinatown temple, trying to piece together words in a dialect I can't understand. I'm listening for the answers to our most important questions, answers that have joined the great catalog of things I'll never hear. I'm more like my grandmother than I thought. I believe those answers exist. They are our fate. They are encoded in every word I write, in the swinging line of my sister's dress. They hover in the room around us, waiting to be seen.
但在我的潜意识里，我正和莎莉站在唐人街庙宇的暗室里，试图拼凑那种我听不懂的方言里的词汇。我在聆听我们最重要的问题的答案，那些答案已经加入了我永远无法听到的伟大目录。我比自己想象的更像我的祖母。我相信这些答案存在。它们就是我们的命运。它们被编码在我写的每一个字里，在我姐姐裙摆摇曳的弧线里。它们悬浮在我们周围的房间里，等待着被看见。
In order of appearance, writers Scott Carrier, David Sedaris, Sarah Vowell, Brady Udall, and Lan Samantha Chang.
按出场顺序，作家有：斯科特·卡里尔、大卫·塞达里斯、萨拉·沃维尔、布雷迪·尤达尔和兰·萨曼莎·张。
[MUSIC - "YOU'LL NEVER KNOW" BY THE PLATTERS]
[音乐 - 派特·布恩的《你永远不会知道》]
Coming up, scientists stumble on a problem they cannot solve. And the only thing they can think of is an act of pure faith. Somewhere, they decide, somewhere, there must exist an invisible particle, a tiny particle with no weight and no charge. And then they go looking for it. What they find, and other unlikely stories of how the world is put together in a minute from Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，科学家们遇到了一个他们无法解决的问题。他们唯一能想到的就是纯粹的信念。他们决定，在某个地方，一定存在一种无形的粒子，一种没有重量、没有电荷的小粒子。然后他们去寻找它。他们发现了什么，以及关于世界是如何构成的其他不可能的故事，节目将在国际公共电台继续播出。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of people to tackle that theme. Today's program, seeing the invisible world, stories of the unseen forces that affect our everyday life and what happens when we finally see them. We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Able To Leap Tall Buildings.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各种各样的人来探讨。今天的节目是“看见隐形世界”，讲述那些影响我们日常生活的无形力量，以及当我们最终看见它们时会发生什么。我们现在进入节目第三幕。第三幕，《能够跳过高楼大厦》。
Well, my friend, I hold in my hand a stack of zines, self-published magazines. They are called Infiltration. The subhead written underneath says, "The zine about going places you're not supposed to go." And people write into this zine from all over the world, mapping out their adventures prowling through construction sites, deserted buildings, steam tunnels under university campuses-- there's a big article here on UCLA-- subway tunnels, abandoned subway stations, drainage pipes, catacombs, plus-- if that were not enough-- the back hallways of hotels, hospitals, office buildings. One article is on an abandoned missile silo in Roswell, New Mexico.
朋友，我手里拿着一堆“自制杂志”（zines）。它们叫《渗透》（Infiltration）。底下的副标题写着：“关于去往你不该去的地方的杂志。”人们从世界各地写信给这份杂志，描述他们潜入建筑工地、废弃建筑、大学校园下的蒸汽隧道——这里有一篇关于UCLA的大文章——地铁隧道、废弃地铁站、排水管、墓穴，还有——如果这还不够的话——酒店、医院、办公楼的后走廊的冒险经历。有一篇文章是关于新墨西哥州罗斯威尔的一座废弃导弹发射井的。
The guy who puts the zine together does not give out his name publicly, but he did agree to an interview from his hometown in Toronto, where he has been sneaking behind the edges of the normal visible world for years.
制作这份杂志的人并没有公开姓名，但他同意在多伦多家乡接受采访，多年来他一直潜行在正常可见世界的边缘。
About three or four years ago, I had to stay in the hospital for several weeks one summer. And while I was confined to the hospital and wasn't allowed to leave, I got very, very bored. So I took to exploring the hospital. Each night, I would walk around in my flimsy little bathrobe and my plastic slippers, and just see all the secret sites of the hospital.
大约三四年前，有一个夏天我不得不住院几周。当被禁锢在医院里不准离开时，我感到非常、非常无聊。所以我开始探索医院。每天晚上，我都会穿着单薄的睡袍和塑料拖鞋四处走动，看看医院里所有的秘密地点。
And what sort of things would you find-- would you see when you walked around?
当你四处走动时，会发现、会看到什么样的东西？
I found abandoned wings in the hospital.
我在医院里发现了被废弃的病区。
Entire wings?
整个病区？
Yeah. So that was really fun. Got to explore all the rooms, and see where patients had been kept, and investigate all the wonderful tools they'd used to heal them. And went down to the morgue and the engineering levels. And managed to get up onto the roof at a few different places.
是的。所以这真的很有趣。可以去探索所有的房间，看看病人被关在哪里，研究他们用来治愈病人的所有奇妙工具。我还去了太平间和工程层。并且设法爬到了几个不同地方的屋顶。
You devoted an entire issue of your zine, Infiltration, to this. And at one point, on page 12, you have a diagram, four photos that's a sort of step-by-step instruction to the reader. Over the photos, it says, "To visit F-wing's locked elevator room, go up this ladder." And there's a photo of the ladder.
你为你杂志的一整期做了这个专题。在第12页，你有一个图表，四张照片，算是给读者的循序渐进的说明。照片上方写着：“要访问F翼锁住的电梯间，走这个梯子。”然后是一张梯子的照片。
And then there's another photo. "Climb through the door, out onto the roof." Shot of the roof. "Find this open window." Shot of the open window. "Lower yourself in and enjoy." And then there's a picture of the locked elevator room.
然后是另一张照片。“从门口爬出去，上到屋顶。”屋顶的镜头。“找到这个打开的窗户。”窗户的镜头。“把自己放进去，享受吧。”然后是一张那个锁住的电梯间的照片。
Yeah, I was really proud of that one, because listening to the whirring and clanking behind that door was driving me mad, because it was always locked every time I checked. And eventually, I found a nice indirect route to get in there. And that was quite a triumph.
是的，我对那个感到非常自豪，因为听着门后传来的嗡嗡声和碰撞声让我发疯，因为每次检查时它总是锁着的。最终，我找到了一个不错的间接路线进去。那真是一次巨大的胜利。
And then once you lower yourself in and enjoy, what's it mean to enjoy that room?
那么，当你进去并“享受”的时候，“享受”那个房间意味着什么？
Well, to savor it. You take the pictures, proving your conquest. You get to understand what was behind all those sounds that you heard from the other side of the door. In this case, it was sort an elevator room. So I realized, a-ha, the reason for those random patterns of sound was people were summoning the elevator at different times. And it was going up different numbers of floors and so on. So it all made sense. It was very satisfying.
嗯，就是品味它。你会拍照，证明你的征服。你会了解你从门那边听到的所有声音背后是什么。在这个案例中，它是一个电梯间。所以我意识到，啊，那些杂乱声音模式的原因是人们在不同时间召唤电梯。它要上到不同的楼层等等。所以这一切都讲得通了。这非常令人满足。
What do you know about this world that is invisible to most of us that the rest of us don't know?
关于这个对我们大多数人来说是隐形的世界，你知道些什么，而我们其他人却不知道？
I don't think I understand it better than the average person. Really, I'm just keenly aware of its presence and impressed by that. Certainly, if there are interesting noises coming from somewhere, I'll pick up on it. Or if I'm walking over a grate, I'll try to figure out what exactly I'm walking on top of.
我不认为我比普通人了解得更深刻。真的，我只是敏锐地意识到它的存在，并对此印象深刻。当然，如果某处传出有趣的噪音，我会察觉到。或者如果我在走过格栅，我会试着弄清楚我到底踩在什么上面。
I never think about grates as something to look down. Will you actually lift up a grate and lower yourself down the ladder to what's there?
我从不把格栅当成可以向下看的东西。你真的会撬开格栅，然后沿着梯子爬下去吗？
Yeah, and that's usually pretty easy to do, at least here in Toronto. It's not too tricky to find an unlocked one. And there is usually a ladder.
会的，这通常很容易做到，至少在多伦多是这样。找到一个没锁的并不太难。而且通常都会有梯子。
What's down there?
下面有什么？
The standard grates that I'm talking about will lead to a network of steam tunnels, which aren't usually accessible directly from the street. They'll just lead to a little hot room with one or more locked doors at the bottom, usually locked.
我说的标准格栅通常会通向一个蒸汽隧道网络，这通常不是从街道直接进入的。它们只会通向一个小小的、热乎乎的房间，底部有一扇或多扇锁着的门，通常是锁着的。
Have you seen the movie The Matrix by any chance?
你有没有看过电影《黑客帝国》？
Yes, I have.
是的，我看过。
I was wondering if you felt a special relationship to that movie in some way, that notion of all of you are seeing this thing that's in front of you, but there's an entire world behind the scrim.
我在想你是否以某种方式对那部电影感到特别的关联，那种你们所有人都能看到眼前的东西，但遮掩物后还有一个完整世界的概念。
Yeah.
是的。
You did?
真的吗？
Yeah, I definitely identified very strongly. It really is like that, because most people have no idea the extent to which they are being coddled and taken care of. The millions and millions of dollars and man hours that go into all the support systems that sustain them and make it possible for them to live in an urban environment.
是的，我确实强烈认同。事实确实如此，因为大多数人根本不知道他们被娇宠和照顾到了什么程度。数以百万计的美元和工时投入到了维持他们生活的支持系统中，使他们有可能在城市环境中生存。
Do you think the rest of us are missing something interesting and important by not seeing this world?
你认为我们其他人因为没有看到这个世界，而错失了什么有趣和重要的事情吗？
Yeah, I really do think so. I think that the secret part of a city is generally much more interesting than the open-to-the-public part. If you know what's going on under the streets-- you know there are another four levels of city underneath the one that you're walking on-- it really adds a lot to your understanding of the world you live in, I think.
是的，我真的这么认为。我认为城市的秘密部分通常比向公众开放的部分有趣得多。如果你知道街道底下发生了什么——你知道在你行走的地面之下还有另外四层城市——我认为这确实增加了你对所居住世界的理解。
You said there are four levels underneath the street level?
你说街道水平面之下有四层？
Oh well, that would probably apply to Toronto where there would be heating tunnels, gas lines, subway tunnels, and then stormwater drains. In Chicago, there would probably be six levels. In New York, there would probably be a good dozen, I would think.
哦，那可能适用于多伦多，那里会有供暖隧道、燃气管道、地铁隧道，然后是雨水渠。在芝加哥，可能有六层。在纽约，我想可能有足足一打。
Is the thing that's the most interesting thing about this secret world the fact that it is secret?
关于这个秘密世界，最有趣的是它很神秘这一事实吗？
If it were open for tours, it would not be that interesting.
如果它开放供参观，就不会那么有趣了。
Now is it true that your devotion to exploring around is so thorough that sometimes you'll be on a date, and you'll see a doorway or whatever and abandon the date?
那传闻说你对探索周围的执着是如此彻底，以至于有时在约会时，你会看到一个门口什么的，就抛下你的约会对象？
That's not an uncommon occurrence for me to ask someone I'm out with to come with me or wait somewhere for me for 10 minutes. I mean sometimes when you see a certain door that's open in a certain way, you know that you'd be missing a huge opportunity if you didn't check it out.
我让跟我出来的人跟我一起去，或者在某处等我10分钟，这对我来说并不罕见。我的意思是，有时当你看到某种以某种方式打开的门时，你知道如果不去检查一下就会错过一个巨大的机会。
Tell me about the most recent time when that's happened.
告诉我最近一次发生这种情况的时候。
That happened a month, month and a half ago, when I was just walking through a subway station and happened to be strolling down a main hallway in the station and noticed out of the corner of my eye that, off, down a hallway a little bit, there was a door open with some unpainted cement behind, which is usually a revealing sign that someone has accidentally left a door open.
那是一个月、一个半月前，我只是在穿过一个地铁站，正巧沿着车站的一条主走廊散步，眼角余光注意到，走廊稍微远处有一扇门开着，后面露出未涂漆的水泥，这通常是一个明显的迹象，表明有人不小心没关门。
So I said to the person I was with, "Will you come and check that out with me?" And she said, "No." So I said, "OK, well, just wait here 10 minutes." And I went through the door, found a tiny little freight elevator, took that down a few levels, wound up in a mechanical room, saw what it had to offer, found I couldn't go back out the same way that I came in, so I had to exit out to the street, and then pay my fare, and come back into the subway station again to meet up with her.
所以我对跟我在一起的人说，“你愿不愿意跟我去看看？”她说，“不。”所以我说，“好吧，那你在这等我10分钟。”我穿过那扇门，发现了一台小小的货运电梯，坐了几层，最后到了一个机械室，看到了它能提供什么，发现不能从原路返回，所以我只好从街道出去，然后重新付费，回到地铁站去和她会合。
It sounds like it took more than 10 minutes.
听起来花了不止10分钟。
It may have taken a little longer than 10 minutes, yes.
是啊，可能花了比10分钟稍微久一点。
So when you're going to go out with somebody, is your motto kind of "bring a book?"
所以当你和某人出去的时候，你的座右铭是“带一本书”吗？
Yeah, well, the kind of people I would go out with would generally be armed with a book, I would say.
是的，好吧，我想我愿意一起出去的人通常都会随身带一本书。
I think overcoming your own mental block against going somewhere you're not supposed to go is usually the biggest hurdle. Most people seem to just have this instinct to stay on path, make sure they only go places they've been clearly told they're allowed to go. They don't need to be told not to go. They actually specifically need to be told that they can enter a place before they will.
我认为克服自己不去“你不该去的地方”的心理障碍通常是最大的困难。大多数人似乎有一种留在路上的直觉，确保他们只去那些被明确告知被允许去的地方。他们不需要被告知不要去。他们实际上特别需要被明确告知可以进入，才会进入。
I've drawn the comparison before that fish farmers, they use these special underwater tanks that blow little tiny oxygen bubbles through tubes. And the fish see a wall of oxygen bubbles, so they don't swim through that wall. The idea is that fish will perceive that there's a solid wall there. And therefore, they'll all stay put. And I think that's the exact same reason why people stay confined to the designated public areas of a street level, rather than fully exploring their environment. They perceive walls that aren't there.
我以前做过比较，鱼类养殖者使用特殊的地下水箱，通过管子吹出微小的氧气泡。鱼看到一道氧气泡墙，所以它们不会游过那道墙。观点是鱼会感知到那里有一堵坚实的墙。因此，它们都会待在原地。我认为这就是人们局限于街道水平面的指定公共区域，而不是充分探索环境的同样原因。他们感知到了并不存在的墙。
The publisher of Infiltration, the zine about going places you're not supposed to go. Their website has the easy-to-remember name www.infiltration.org.
《渗透》的发行人，那本关于去往你不该去的地方的杂志。他们的网站有一个容易记住的名字：www.infiltration.org。
Act Four, Look, Up In The Sky. Well, astrophysicists have come to believe that the universe is made up more of things that we cannot see-- dark matter, subatomic particles-- than things we can see. And one way to describe the process of science is that it chases after and names what is invisible to us. Nancy Updike invites you to consider the case of one subatomic particle, the neutrino.
第四幕，《看，在天空中》。天体物理学家已经开始相信，宇宙中更多是由我们看不见的东西——暗物质、亚原子粒子——组成的，而不是可见的东西。描述科学过程的一种方法是，它追寻并命名那些对我们隐形的事物。南希·厄普代克邀请您审视一种亚原子粒子：中微子。
What you are sitting there right now not feeling yourself experiencing is the passage through your body, every second, of hundreds of neutrinos. They are so small that, to a neutrino, your body is mostly the empty space between the atoms, space for it to move through at the speed of light. Now neutrinos are able to do this because they have no electric charge and practically no weight. They are about 10 million times lighter than the smallest atomic particle. No one has ever seen one.
你现在坐在这里没有感受到的，是每秒钟都有数百个中微子穿过你的身体。它们非常小，对中微子来说，你的身体大部分是原子之间的空隙，让它以光速穿过的空间。现在中微子能够做到这一点，因为它们没有电荷，也没有重量。它们比最小的原子粒子还要轻约1000万倍。没有人见过它。
The most abundant natural source of neutrinos in this corner of the galaxy is the sun, which releases neutrinos during nuclear reactions at its core. These neutrinos travel through space, unchanged, without stopping, forever. And since they're unchanged, they're one of the few ways we have to figure out exactly what's going on at the sun's core.
在星系的这个角落，中微子最丰富的自然来源是太阳，它在核心的核反应中释放中微子。这些中微子穿过空间，保持不变，不停留，永远地运动。由于它们保持不变，它们是我们弄清太阳核心究竟发生了什么的极少数途径之一。
So here's the equipment we, as a species, chose to use to try to confirm the existence of these delicate, elusive particles. A solid rock chamber dug into a gold mine in South Dakota, a metal tank the size of a small ranch house, and, inside the tank, 100,000 gallons of--
所以这是我们作为一个物种选择使用的设备，试图证实这些微妙、难以捉摸的粒子的存在。一个挖在南达科他州金矿里的坚固岩石室，一个小型牧场房屋大小的金属罐，在罐子里有10万加仑的——
Dry cleaning fluid.
干洗液。
Yes, dry cleaning fluid. Because it's cheap, and because it contains chlorine. Ray Davis is the chemist who designed this experiment, which is called Homestake. He's been studying solar neutrinos for 30 years.
是的，干洗液。因为便宜，而且含有氯。雷·戴维斯是设计这个实验的化学家，这个实验叫Homestake。他研究太阳中微子已经30年了。
The more liquid you have and the bigger the thing is, the more you capture in the tank.
液体越多，东西越大，你在罐子里捕获的就越多。
So it just increases the likelihood?
所以这只是增加了可能性？
Yes.
是的。
Because you have to account for the fact that most neutrinos are just going to keep going and are not going to be stopped.
因为你必须考虑到大多数中微子只是会继续运动，而不会被阻挡。
Yes, most of them don't interact at all. I mean they just go right through the tanks as if it wasn't there, and the liquid, the whole thing, and go out the mine the other way and go to Japan. Now that's the way neutrinos are.
是的，它们大多数根本不发生相互作用。我的意思是，它们直接穿过罐子，好像那东西不存在，液体也是，整个东西，然后从矿井的另一边出去，去了日本。中微子就是这样。
Here's how it works. The chlorine in dry cleaning fluid, when it's bombarded with neutrinos, produces atoms of a radioactive gas called argon-37. And when you count up the argon-37 atoms you've collected in the tank, you know that for each argon atom, one neutrino passed through the tank. I know all of this because I've been obsessed with neutrinos ever since I first talked to Ray four years ago. And I have to tell you that I am here as an advocate, a fan. I don't just want you to understand neutrinos. I want you to love them.
它是这样工作的。干洗液中的氯，当中微子撞击它时，会产生一种叫氩-37的放射性气体的原子。当你数清你在罐子里收集到的氩-37原子时，你就知道每有一个氩原子，就有一个中微子穿过了罐子。我知道这一切是因为自从四年前我第一次和雷谈过之后，我就对中微子着了迷。我必须告诉你，我在这里是一个倡导者，一个粉丝。我不仅希望你了解中微子。我希望你爱上它们。
Consider their history. Neutrinos weren't discovered so much as imagined as a bizarre answer to an especially thorny problem. In the early part of this century, scientists thought they understood pretty well the basic workings of the atom. But when they measured the amount of energy atoms give off during radioactive decay, the numbers didn't come out right. Now, they could have concluded that perhaps our understanding of the atom was wrong, but they didn't. They came up with something that, to a non-scientist, seems a lot crazier.
看看它们的历史。中微子的发现与其说是被发现，不如说是为了回答一个特别棘手的问题而被想象出来的。在这个世纪初期，科学家们认为他们很了解原子的基本运作方式。但当他们测量原子在放射性衰变过程中释放的能量时，数字对不上。他们本来可以得出结论说，也许我们对原子的理解错了，但他们没有。他们想出了一些在非科学家看来疯狂得多的东西。
Wolfgang Pauli suggested that maybe something comes out you can't see.
沃尔夫冈·泡利建议，也许有一些你看不见的东西跑出来了。
Wolfgang Pauli was exactly the sort of scientist who could say something like that with a straight face. "Hey, maybe what's happening here is that a particle is coming out that we can't see, a special, secret, invisible particle." Since Pauli was smarter than almost everyone else, nobody told him he was nuts. In fact, other scientists took his idea very seriously.
沃尔夫冈·泡利正是那种能面不改色地说出这种话的科学家。“嘿，也许这里发生的是跑出来了一个我们看不见的粒子，一种特殊的、秘密的、隐形的粒子。”由于泡利比几乎所有其他人都聪明，没有人说他疯了。事实上，其他科学家非常认真地对待他的想法。
And Fermi--
还有费米——
This is Enrico Fermi, a scientist.
这是恩里科·费米，一位科学家。
Enrico Fermi. He'd developed a theory that would take this into account, and he called this "the neutrino," the little, neutral one. He said, the particle is neutral, and it should be almost impossible to detect. And for many years, that was a real problem.
恩里科·费米。他开发了一种能够解释这一点的理论，他称之为“中微子”，即“微小的、中性的那个”。他说，这个粒子是中性的，应该几乎无法探测到。多年来，这确实是个问题。
This was the problem that Ray Davis started with as a young chemist after World War II. He wanted to detect neutrinos. Since the lab where he worked had a nuclear reactor on site, and since neutrinos are continually emitted during nuclear reactions, he decided to start there with, of course, some dry cleaning fluid in a relatively small container, a 55-gallon drum. It didn't work.
这就是雷·戴维斯在二战后作为一名年轻化学家开始着手解决的问题。他想探测中微子。因为他工作的实验室现场有核反应堆，而中微子在核反应过程中会持续发射，他决定从那里开始，当然，是用装在相对较小的容器里的干洗液，一个55加仑的桶。没起作用。
You have to have a more sensitive detector. And you have to go underground.
你必须有更灵敏的探测器。而且你必须去到地下。
Underground, so that the earth would shield the experiment from other particles from space that kept confusing Ray's results. Thus began Ray's seemingly counterintuitive plan to pursue one of the universe's most minuscule, ethereal particles by building bigger and bigger containers and moving them further and further underground. Until finally, he was building a 100,000-gallon tank a mile underground.
地下，这样地球就可以保护实验免受其他来自太空、不断干扰雷的实验结果的粒子的影响。雷那看似反直觉的计划就这样开始了：通过建造越来越大的容器，并把它们越放越深，去追踪宇宙中最微小、最空灵的粒子之一。直到最后，他正在地下一英里处建造一个10万加仑的罐子。
I can show you some pictures of these.
我可以给你看几张这些照片。
Yeah, I'd love to see them. Oh, that's the tank.
是的，我很想看。噢，那是那个罐子。
That's the tank.
那是那个罐子。
It looks like a huge vitamin capsule.
看起来像个巨大的维生素胶囊。
Yes, the engineers call that a horizontal blimp. And it's a tank that's about 50 feet long and 20 feet in diameter. Now these are the posts that--
是的，工程师们称之为“水平飞艇”。这是一个大约50英尺长、20英尺直径的罐子。现在这些是那些支柱——
Gosh, it's huge! There's a man standing there, and he--
天哪，它太大了！有个男人站在那儿，他——
That's me.
那是我。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Some man standing there.
某个站在那儿的男人。
One of the great things about Homestake is that it was almost written off as a complete flop. But over time, it proved itself right and changed forever the way we look at the sun. Basically, Homestake challenged decades of accepted stellar evolution theory. Ray was supposed to register 10 neutrinos a day in his tank, and that number was based on careful calculations using everything scientists already knew about nuclear processes. Instead, Ray saw only two neutrinos a day. And his results never changed significantly.
Homestake实验最棒的地方之一是，它几乎被判定为彻底失败。但随着时间推移，它证明了自己的正确，并永远改变了我们看待太阳的方式。基本上，Homestake挑战了数十年来被接受的恒星演化理论。雷的罐子应该每天记录10个中微子，那个数字是根据科学家们已知的核过程进行仔细计算得出的。相反，雷每天只看到两个中微子。而且他的结果从未有显著改变。
And no one could explain the problem of the missing neutrinos other than to tell Ray his experiment just wasn't working. It wasn't until other neutrino detectors started being built in the 1980s that Ray's results were confirmed once and for all. And scientists finally began to face the mess that neutrinos presented them with.
没有人能解释缺失中微子的问题，只能告诉雷他的实验根本没起作用。直到20世纪80年代开始建造其他中微子探测器，雷的结果才被彻底证实。科学家们终于开始正视中微子给他们带来的混乱。
There's the science of things you can see and touch, surgeons studying the heart, Diane Fossey out there with the gorillas. And there's the science of things you can't see. When Ray started his neutrino experiments, the director of his lab tried to warn him off. He only liked science he could see.
有你可以看见和触碰的事物的科学，外科医生研究心脏，黛安·弗西在户外研究大猩猩。还有一种看不见的事物的科学。当雷开始他的中微子实验时，他的实验室主任试图劝阻他。他只喜欢他能看见的科学。
A guy that works on things that are in the laboratory, hands-on, that do this and that, you know where you stand. When you get up to the middle of the sun, you're kind of in deep water, and you do the best you can.
一个在实验室里做事情的人，亲自动手，做这个那个，你知道你的立场。当你上升到太阳中心时，你就像在深水区，你尽你所能。
I'm on the other side of the argument from Ray's former boss. I'm all for invisibility. I think it imposes humility, and that's a good thing. No one has ever seen a neutrino, no scientist, no fan. In the face of neutrinos, we are all fumbling around in the middle of the sun, doing the best we can. What we can't see rules us, love, God, neutrinos, radio.
我站在雷的前老板的对立面。我完全支持隐形。我认为它强加了谦卑，这是一件好事。没有人见过中微子，没有科学家，也没有粉丝。面对中微子，我们都在太阳中心摸索，尽我们所能。那些我们看不见的东西统治着我们，爱、上帝、中微子、无线电。
But I think we want to be ruled. We want God to be ineffable. We want love to mysteriously endure after our physical presence is gone. We want to know that neutrinos are moving through us and continuing on, unchanged forever. Everything we can see has an explanation and an end. And we don't want everything to end.
但我认为我们想要被统治。我们希望上帝是不可言说的。我们希望爱在我们肉体存在消失后神秘地永存。我们希望知道中微子正在穿过我们，并继续运动，永远不变。一切我们能看见的东西都有解释，也都有终点。而我们不想让一切都结束。
Nancy Updike.
南希·厄普代克。
Well, our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and myself with Susan Burton, Blue Chevigny, Julie Snyder, and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margie Rochlin, Alix Spiegel, and  consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Starlee Kine.
好了，今天的节目由亚历克斯·布隆伯格和我本人制作，苏珊·伯顿、蓝色·切维尼、朱莉·斯奈德和南希·厄普代克参与。特约编辑：保罗·托夫、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和“参谋”萨拉·沃维尔。制作协助：托德·巴赫曼和斯塔莉·基恩。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Or you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
如需购买本节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥WBEZ电台的电话：312-832-3380。或者您可以在我们的网站www.thislife.org免费收听我们大部分的节目。感谢运营网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特。《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金来源鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who wishes to take a moment to send this message to his masters back in the Soviet Union.
WBEZ管理监督：托里·马拉蒂亚，他希望花点时间向他在苏联的头子们发送这条信息。
Bravo, Delta, Two, Niner, One, Charlie, Foxtrot.
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回到《美国生活》，带来更多故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共电台。